this Christmas shoppers are set to spend
billions of pounds on toys in the UK but
with some of the latest must-have toy
tech gadgets come serious security
concerns the consumer group which has
found a number of smart toys could leave
children at risk of being contacted by
strangers
we tested 7 children's connected toys
that are sold across major retailers in
the UK such as John Lewis Amazon Argos
and Smith's and found that three of them
had security flaws that would enable
someone else to connect to the toy and
potentially communicate with the child
playing with it
smart toys in the UK are being marketed
to children as youngest three years old
but how do those buying toys this
Christmas feel about this potential
security failure yes quite worrying it's
a thing you've got to think about I mean
nowadays as technology's changing
there's lots of barriers and things
they've put up so we'll see see how code
as it goes up for now we know we might
buy the NCC group works with the
government on legislation when it comes
to cyber security the owners should
really sit with the manufacturer they're
the people that are designing the toys
they're the people that are responsible
for manufacturing them they need to be
responsible for ensuring that the toy is
safe before it goes on sale whilst the
way these toys are manufactured maybe
the issue here though selling them have
come under intense scrutiny we contacted
all four retailers for a response to the
report but only two responded in a
statement Amazon told Sky News we
require all products offered in our
store to comply with applicable laws and
regulations and we proactively monitor
multiple sources for safety
notifications including from regularity
agencies and direct contacts from brands
manufacturers and sellers whilst John
Lewis said we take the security and
privacy of connected devices very
seriously we have been working to
explore how we can best support the
voluntary code of
practice which improves the security of
connected technology products but now
the consumer group is urging the next
government to bring in specific
legislation to keep children safe we are
calling on the next government to start
looking at mandatory requirements and
manufacturers to ensure that products
are secure before they put them on sale
millions of toys will be wrapped up and
popped under trees across the UK this
Christmas but the drive to get connected
could be coming at the cost of privacy
security and the safety of children in
Zaman rasheed Sky News